Михайло Борисович Михайло Борисович
дуже дякую ще приводу la si do the
interview д.р. я озирнувся ваш з
прийняти а жити і людей з готову яко
ви вийшли на волю після того, як ви
вийшли на свободу я дуже радий сьогоднішній
я навіть раді сьогоднішній нашій з вами
розмари і завжди радість вам та спилку
хвилюйся я на дуже люблю
заряду ти в минуло і темпу джеани дуже
люблю я нехай собі кулемети
до в'язниці і після цілих ширу [ __ ] inci
люди інші люди мені здається що я став
ми не здається що я пішов ставити ти
сюди людських на долі kill
spooky ніші не стала вся раніше ну від
шиви дно після нг впав з людьми
week їх на частки кіу і ноги на віч більше
не думаю іноді навіть більше, ніж у мене
ви раніше займалися і ми раніше
займався бізнесом
за раз займаємось на морську
діяльністю диким та важких чим і
виїзді що вх null і всяких ви навчи
кулони і не підозрював шукаю тут е такі
проблеми та проблеми для мене для мене був і
куїнна спуді він ку думаю я до і для
багатих стала радикально змії на
ментальності російської істоти після
початку всі ці та українську епопею
після початку ось все це українське поп
і я все-таки думав що наша істота на
на стейка хвора
ви та морським синдромом де ми з вами
синдромом а по-друге на мене виявилося
несподіванкою
що громадська діяльність
а інша для мінові волосяних під диван.
дещо граматика діянь я здається
третя сфера місяця на стиль ким менше
ефективно з вирубні чую точка зору та
на устілці внутрішню конкурентно
на психологічному рівні пурим ненавидь
з бізнесом настільки всередині
неконкурентна
на психологічному рівні порівняно
навіть з бізнесом мені здавалося, що ми не
здавалася і що тут до 9 раз думати і
ситуація могла б but i wish me дещо
виручку і більш м'якої сталі більше
товариської ну але заспівав але ми не
штани роздувати дати себе загадувати з
дику ностальгію фрукти в бізнесі я дати
його звук ціну я до цього звик від
нормально а ви розумієте лави розуміє і
що у вас покарають усі ці люди ділити
явно не влада точно на владу може
чого зазвичай люди річки представляють
ліберальний tabbert на пробувати про
влади та шанси винен позови як виявилося
це для мене несподівано ви знаєте які
його лося і c для мене нас по дивані
для багатих людей горизонт їхнього
найбільшого теж не застигла і пак
широкий горизонт країни
робіт їм занепалий свиту і від народу
орендується на те, що його живим у них
душа маленького світла a supple його
сьогодні
класу тягнемо і реджі дозволяють це
сильно на брат і багато людей
відчувати
вісь zeiss вигляд набирати багато людей
чисельно створюють ось цей ось світ і
ти не бачиш що ось ці ось і ти на вигляд
не бачиш рахунку 5 10 то на 50 тисяч
людей і кіста але влити твоїй точці в
суть вони морозі цін нас правді душа
невелика частина і на глобальному на вигляд
дуже мала частина світового світу
по спинці у вихованців є будьте
10200 частіше
з'явилися ще не чуйні в російських
проти чого вид криту росію хоче в
росії за буруни ти че реально
че монті чуйні пити собою пит грунті та
яким і якимець повернутися можна його
реалізувати та юридично яма на вазі
свистну організацію та відкрито росія та
відкрито росію там давно забрано в
Росії відбувається осінь then в Росії і
відбувається дуже сіка vinas правді і
піди і все спільна можете вкрай
реакційно
я вкрай реакцію на крило і до його зараз
на мага і тебе просто ухну то якись
максимально жорсткі заходи і я думаю що
він і просто не дивуюсь куди б не
хотів і зайти в народжений шт
у мого розуміння для них ігіл
може б ніби такий суді якусь куди ванни
промити на щастя все-таки на щастя
все-таки для російського сусп листя
розум владу шведа кинься на покинув щоб
ми про неї наговорив і його на свист
адже ступаючи підпискам свого
радикального крила тому що ви на
його сру було ставку цьому навіяно йому і
ти на вчинки
олл-ін і так швидкою як це радикальне
крило вистачило але не так швидко як це
б радикальне крило хотіла тобто я
думаю що путін пройде цей шлях топ то
я думаю що путін пройдеться і шлях як
що в соромно
до православної та справи холодця будеш
чудо садові шлях вірші точка зору на
сьогоднішній день став місяць до відкритого
русі прагне ви могли дієти
за закон дотримується вимог
діяти за законом якщо мови year
мови для тих людей ці позови проти 2
криту росію і проти самих русів і в
Росії безсумнівно на ризики є і без
нього різак і.
6-е і точка зору я обожнюю що нинішня
російська влада
більше світу і висловлюємо максиму я кусова
красу сурма лего на мою мусоліну
друзям з врагом закон друзям все
ворогам закон ви розумієте а ви розумієте
і який крим чи
а.п. хвалите і рішення я король у в'язницю
краю владимир путін нас скільки можна
прогнозу і ті рішення ці будуть у
хвала не ці політичні кров і які
будуть тут нами
чсс фільму насту диваном есма несподівано
я вважаю що сьогодні
якщо й неможливо передбачити кожен
конкретний крок я вважаю що сьогодні я до
іншому жив його перед більш так один
конкретне коло
то загальна з перебування крутив силоміць у
але й силоміць перед баштовим ми з вами
розуміє йому що головна проблема ті з
системи управління іржаву побуду
вал владимир путін куляїв тому що німа
in шева джерело light їм насти у влади
крем-суп з того путіна та його рейтинг у
результаті вся чиновниць карати uri
інтуїція тільки на 2 параметри перший
параметр t що сказав путін перший акт
що я шанс, що путін циpка метати
сказав путін якщо є шанс що путін
це помітить 2 і другий параметр інший
параметр що ви і дно для мийок рішення про
скільки
володимир путін все-таки всі малюки люди
на до того ж люди на які нас виклала
проти ти вже кути витяжку відразу мило
що кілька ,
річки знаходяться у свого без посередника
вагай на така вже його лика за раз ти
раніше за зовнішнім політика є мета вин
в основному у купе кається зараз швидше
це зовнішня політика
ось там він в основному займається те, що
стосується внутрішніх робимо почуття до
внутрішніх право wingo ж htc невелика
проблема
і у війна c особливо азарту і отже
те що ж буває з рада не країни
боротьба різних груп за ресурс слова
боротьба
регіонали хоче свого слова ти хочеш
свого pet pro mc у тому числі близькі до
володимира путіна погіршити свого вісь у
рамках цех битви за ресурс і адже буває
вся внутрішня політика в тому числі і те
та кобудо на виборах 2016 уроку я queen
робот ви без тут th дуже прості
алгоритми путін завжди вибирає дай
рішення катрина їх у думка на доступному
вкрийте даю йому більше чоловік новин
вибору ось це стандартний алгоритм
when we днем ​​практично ніколи нагору
дати цей стандартний алгоритм він від
його практично ніколи не відходить що
відбувається що буваєте на вашу
думку ухилився нах нижче рамзаном
кадировим і володимиром путіним
я король за 1 рамзан кадиров граючи в
російський політик це нас кілька в СРСР
Путін працювати з ним і ти якийсь прямо і
конфлікт з ним йти на якийсь прямий
конфлікт
я вважаю що я люблю що путін про
червону іншу розуму принести системи
старим його нею і протезах і в скільки у
нього на mail та бальну систему
стриманий він і протезах як вона закріплена в
конституції між канавкою закону
дала владу
на закладеним судом романським сусп рст
вам про знижку цілей системи стримування ванні
правах міньйони травня to win з чоловіком
створі ось і sf das ist
кадиров з його банда має загалом і
втерти в саду системі
свисну кадиров з його банди травня дощок
серйозно значення цьому
дестабілізації бік у нього в улові
систему виводить кадирова з гри квн
завершуючи але як ми bашему на прикладі
розслідування в буйство бориса на
готовий вбивству бориса він не готовий ви
їм ще давно сказала про ти ще
російські громадян і на зуби в я за
його кону води на праву це нас
провідними законами
було волочил на дошку щастя біля приводу
червона як засовує і практично на душі
відразу мило і ці критерії розмежування
mesh справедливим та законом це на
справедливим і
і на правовому та олайя головні відповідаю за
харчування яхти на практиці розтушовуються
і всі ви навик він його це закон околиці
то шанси того, що вас зачепа карає
на високі нічого не відомо на друг
путіна з вас його воріт таки вже не
мати та капот античність
колима не тип це не я так формулює
темою ж завжди наші спи в vici знаки
знімає ж це майже завжди наші
співвітчизники з Німеччини 3 оприлюднять
і що частка закінчив
по три вагони ці в Росії і до слова в
Радонезькому союзі дата вузли чайному
жити і вигляд 30 до 60 і сотки
особливо його закон послуг няні громадян та
законі в іконою моди його штифт 10
випадок до хвани знають що ви не навик він
її закони
а все менше ви на нього до ночі тому що
ван і не знають що c і закон дробові
конова цей закон треба виконувати
у ЗМІ з'явилася інформація я не змія
була вся інформація що роз'їдаються
варіант ще лідером та триги політичної
партії парнас на виборах угу 2016
потворності може з татою люди з веденим і
примарою і з рідних назвав її вашого
сина павла
нібито вставати і сядуть їжі і
їжу у частини павла у рибальської компанії
павла у виборній кампанії я до подібного
роду провокації їм адміністрація до
таких провокацій адміністрації
президента від нього у нього суми вашому
джерело тих джейн шах ідей підкинуть їх у
змі
cb сум його було а.п. я даних вставлю
ся з гумором добрі хлопці протерти буде
добре хлопці працюють молодці це
смішно слухати, а як ви майже владно
політично мої будні я був бум і е
люди ну я здати напливу ти на процеси
що і думається в краї не я одягаюсь а
що мої будь йому cs барижать у майбутньому
це зберігатися особистих немає усу швидких
політичних амбіцій на моїй шиї ємність
духу струкова завдання від шиї ви зі
сприймає і наполегливому сенсі ок
mission піонери для мене зовсім не
очевидний для ми на абсолютно ночі помітний
графік змін столітті будуть видуватися в
російському політичному жити і я вже
говорив що на мою думку 24 рік цінної
пак так і ерік схожий на годину гул і
настануть xmin і
all іван і може адже сара ніша і
він і може нажаль
вигляд ніби себе пісні я буду вата якісь
конкретніше слони особи на такий вигляд
дав йому перспективу
щось чуєш а ну вільні у булгакова
блок до волі смішним а я нам е пом'ята
це в нього проблема людей не в тому
що воно смертне а в тому з чого на rab
то вас енергії людини не в тому що але
смерті на тому що раптово як ви
ставитеся ідуть овочу russian і готова ви
кону води рішення міжнародних судити
за поза вам юкоса легко
юкоса мене був дуже здивувало якби
сьогоднішній момент вже здавала нібито
сьогоднішня росія та сьогоднішня влада
була б готова рубати тобто для неї
фінансово на
видно від жуки роз'їдають сьогоднішній
російський бюджет
nex-6 що коштувати на службі російського
держави
он і розридаюсь сьогоднішні бюджету я
Качусь що ж класти у них не до шини і
ось он і
довжину 10 рішення виймають та роздають
громадян його щоб ти замок-то
є вже лежить у їхній кишені і ось
вони іноді з цієї кишені
виймають та й роздають там громадянам що
вони заткнулися
а тут ворогам виду ти щоб все що вороги
перестала ніби в ураган і
але навряд чи он і перестануть ніби
ворогами
просто тому що процес біля воріт закон
що таке закон
складаються що ми що дня перепишу йому не
ціна тикал
часто запитують а як я дивлюся на
часто намагаюся щось задасть skoda
російським громадян of і б російсько
адже влада є момент захотіла в ціні
ти я сама ніби за законом щоб бачив
ці акції століття вона на законі виклала у
десятки в тисячі актори рябова ці акції
які вона незаконно вилучила у десятків
тисяч акціонерів до речі наблизь хоч до
церкви додайте акції на напада кових
аукціонах і кіно відразу мило всяких
причин з умовної укус люблять все
спрямованим на кью касу вважаються вони
праведні ви нам просто teac te повернула
назад компанія з ну і називається зростання
на авто і для російського пара сич
наваром 1 і на нічого б змінилося і
закладено вигляд того кому накласти тайчі та
не пакет акцій зростання назвати чомусь не
хочу борошно лиж неактивної рай укусу на
буя тираж-то води моєму російському
федерації за кордоном з до федерації за
кордоном і наскільки ефективно з точки
зору вранці вони я компенсації
мені ось ціль і нескладно сказали я la2 у
є щоб леонід борисович невзлін а
Бог тобто з моїх колег у залечу 8
боялася чогось бояться ми
а ви самі мінятися самому чого маніту
самому навчання
пройшов вшита що я прийшов і у в'язниці і
до в'язниці чого боятися завалити так
Малайці зуби ти пораниш і з меншими
проблемами дати англійський мазок одопту
ці
ліга такий вже чудово зрозумів і що у
буде і момент геть і може стати жертвою
Однак краще видно на поверх дати
їй думка
з викл і не бачимо вони теж із цією думкою
залоз
дякую навіть вам якусь